How much do you feel you know about my work?
Nothing.
What is my job title?
Baker boy?
I'm done.
You're the...
Where do I work?
You work at places with six names.
What the hell is that?
That's not the name of our company.
That's the name of our website.
What's the name of the company?
Okay, how would you describe the sort of things I do at work?
Well, I think you do all the work, I can't see the partners doing any work.
Basically, you cook stuff.
Frankly, I think in a few more years,..
...if you don't do well, you might as well pack it up.
What would your number one piece of career advice be?
Forget plan b.
Get a job.
Become a millionaire.
Am I doing the job you hoped I'd be doing?
I'm not disappointed.
Okay.
I'm just proud of you.
I know that you got quite a big job.
What do you think you would be like in my job?
I might do a bad job.
Would you like to see my workplace?
Yeah, I can do the catering!
Do we get lunch?
Yeah.
Yeah, then I want to.